[Music]
[Applause]
it's opening day Jeff passen's hair
looks crisp maybe a little extra product
in there the Baseball Insider for ESPN
he'll be on baseball tonight pregame
show tonight at six Eastern it's
Baseball opening night it'll be the
Astros hosting the White Sox at seven
o'clock great to see you again Jeff can
you please help me understand why the
Unicorn is opening the season on the
road in Oakland instead of being
showcased like he should be
shohei uttani national TV
yeah I I don't uh I don't necessarily
disagree with your premise other than
maybe MLB wanted a no-hitter on opening
day that's what I said but but I I don't
want it to be late at night no-hitter we
need we need shohei utani should be in
Prime Time given everything that's
happened in baseball or even make it an
afternoon game but yeah people want to
see him after what's happened and you're
not you're not taking advantage of that
why I I I I don't have a good answer to
that honestly I don't think there is one
I agree if there's any cajoling of the
schedule that Major League Baseball
should be doing it's for the beginning
of the season and it should be tilted
toward the stars and having shohei Otani
open in New York would have been
incredible having him pitch on opening
day at Fenway Park would have been
amazing or uh in in Philadelphia against
the defending national league champions
or we could go on and on
all the different things that could have
been I I suppose I take solace in
knowing that it's just one day and I
understand like it's a ceremonial one
it's national holiday for those of us
who love baseball but because of the
balanced schedule this year that has
never been in place in the past oh Tony
is going to be playing everywhere this
year so he will have those games at
Yankee Stadium and he will have those
games in Citi Field and he will have
those games in Boston that we're all
Desiring it just won't be on this day
that all of us are sitting here excited
about the what the next 186 days have to
hold
is Otani on the Angels by the end of the
year
oh boy see when when you ask that
question you're essentially asking me to
make a prediction about how the angels
are going to do this year and I do think
the angels are going to be an improved
team
I don't know that they're going to be
improved enough necessarily such that
when August 1st the trade deadline comes
around they don't sit there and say we
can get so much and secure our future
for somebody who in all likelihood is
going to be leaving at the end of this
season and and that's the you know
that's the Catch-22 for the Angels right
now they know that in order to have any
shot at keeping shohei Otani around they
need to win this year and and they know
that you know I think they probably felt
that in the past but I think they know
it explicitly now after seeing him
during the World Baseball Classic
um I've been around you on and off for
five years now that he's been over here
and
there was a different version of him
than at the WBC the guy at the WBC was
the team captain of Samurai Japan a
group of players who have gone and won
Olympic gold medals and who played
together all they were the you know one
of only a handful of real teams as
opposed to guys who have just gotten
thrown together for the WBC and seeing
the utter Joy on his face and the
excitement of playing baseball that
counts for him like that really makes
him care you know he said after the
semi-final game uh where they had the
walk-off hit against Mexico
um you know this is the most fun I've
had playing baseball in a long time and
it's the most fun because he's been
winning and he hasn't won it all in his
time with the angels so I I you know
this is dancing around your original
question uh if if the Angels win they
will keep him and they will use that as
a selling point to try and keep him from
going to the Dodgers or the Mets or the
Giants or the Yankees or the Mariners
the teams that seem to be the top
suiters for him this is a team that
finished 33 games out of first place
last year
Vegas DraftKings has them over under 82
and a half wins yep that's I mean show a
utani's got to look at Mike Trout and go
do I want this do I because yeah I mean
you know Mike Trout Mike I think Mike
Trout looked at Mike Trout and says who
I want yes and and remember Mike Trout's
got the biggest contract in baseball
history at 426 and a half million
dollars but Mike Trout also hasn't been
to the playoffs since
2014. against cancer and yeah yep and in
that playoff series The Angels got swept
so Mike Trout is a decade plus Stan into
his career
and still has not won a playoff game so
these are you know these are fair
questions to ask and uh I I don't
anticipate Mike Trout asking out anytime
soon but man if shohei of Tani were to
leave just what a punch to the gut that
would be for this organization that
frankly was given a gift you know Tommy
coming over I mean there is there's no
player in baseball history who has been
has underpaid as he is relative to where
he would be on the open market and I
think we're going to see that this off
season when his contract starts with the
number five and potentially like this is
wild to say maybe even the number six
talking to Jeff pass an ESPN senior
Baseball Insider
how good of a month was this for Major
League Baseball
oh my gosh
um so let's go over the the three high
points to me uh number one the WBC was
awesome I I don't care who you root for
there's always something about when
professional athletes play for their
countries whether it's the World Cup the
Olympics that brings out something
different than them like a side of them
that they may not have recognized part
of that is being with a team of guys who
are All-Stars and who are the best in
their field but part of it also is
culture and Heritage and that deep place
that it holds inside of our souls and so
I I saw a different sort of intensity in
March which you never see in baseball it
is the most lackadaisical laid-back slow
month on the calendar because you're
just playing out the string until
opening day so to have those games in
the WBC I think a lot of people are
going to be looking forward to the World
Baseball Classic when it comes back in
2026. uh today you've got the pitch
clock
and the band shift and the bigger bases
and the lack of pick-off moves that are
going to fundamentally change baseball
and I I'm not exaggerating when I say
this it's not just the 25 minutes of
game time that got shaved off during
spring training it's the fact that it's
a brand of baseball that's a lot closer
to what you saw in the 70s and 80s where
it's not going to be as intensely
focused around the Home Run where
left-handers are still going to be able
to hit singles to right field where
stolen base is down I think might double
this year compared to last year but
really where it's moving at a place that
you can't look down at your phone in
between pitches without running the risk
of missing one and it's going to take a
little while for fans I think to get
used to because it is an alarming
jarring change when you see it for the
first time but players have gotten used
to it and I think for the most part they
are very very much on board with it and
then last night
the first minor league collective
bargaining agreement if we look back at
history minor league baseball players
have been treated poorly for upwards of
a century like it's been a really really
long time that they have been paid
poverty wages that they've played and
dilapidated stadiums that they've been
on buses that break down that they've
had to sleep six to a two-bedroom
apartment because they couldn't afford
anymore and the fact that they within
the last year were able to create a
union become recognized by Major League
Baseball and hammer out a collective
bargaining agreement that will more than
double their salaries before opening day
provide housing better food etc etc it's
just a seminal day in baseball history
that that and opening day with the pitch
clock and the other new rules are all
happening in these last 24 hours all
right briefly on these teams the Astros
season hinges on
uh who did I put I wrote that a week and
a half ago so you need to remember
Altuve
two months I you know honestly the
Astros are so good that their season
doesn't necessarily hinge on anyone like
they they have they have such depth that
was just a product Dan
um this thing's been hinging on a player
for many other teams I don't want to
include the Astros so okay how about the
Braves season hinges on
yeah this is another one I don't
remember really this uh segment is going
in you you wrote this you wrote it
Words If You're Expecting to be the 120
different bits all right okay all right
you know what no no
I'm calling you out this
this Ritz gets for not paying for ESPN
plus I get an email last night hey can
you send me the text from this article
and I was like wow why do you want the
text from that article you cheat
bastards pay for Plus
hey I built the damn place
they should give it to me for free
passing just keep that in mind talking
hairdo going in and taking a Victory lap
I spent 18 years I built the damn place
don't you talk don't you talk to Todd
that way and you got my hair back when I
was there come on
I'm not gonna put up with this how about
that Todd thanks for sticking up thank
you all right I used to love Jeff yeah
see what he did throw me under the bus
there
I was going to ask you what the Dodger
season hinges on are the Yankees but I I
don't want to I don't want to stump you
[Laughter]
okay that's it that's you know passing
picks on fritzy and then it's ball game
all right hey I I deeply respect you
standing up for your people in that
matter
um I I do however just have to say
my hair is better than yours was in your
Prime
to Bristol I you know I know where
passing is no no it's good it can say it
wow he can sit go ahead uh I'm okay with
that I could refresh your memory this is
a great final time on The Dan Patrick
Show yes yeah uh Todd get Buster only on
the phone if you can yeah
yes Paul Jeff I'm all for
self-confidence and I love your work but
let's pump the brakes yeah
I I mean honestly yeah it's probably
true but I just after after you coming
back at me I felt like some bravado was
necessary you don't have to be Robin
Ventura I'm Nolan Ryan on the mound you
don't have to come out Jeff stay there
you know
and and and uh have some fun today so I
know you will and uh thank you again for
all your contributions
I always appreciate and Todd I I still
like you I I love you in fact and Dan
thank you for having such great hair all
right thank you Jeff that's Jeff pass an
ESPN senior Baseball Insider you can see
that here tonight on baseball tonight
starting at six Eastern it's opening
night it'll be the Astros and the White
Sox at 7.